[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos happy happy New
Year happy 2023. what a great way for us
to start off the year with an incredible
fun delightful conversation with the
incredible funny and delightful
otsuko okatsuka otsuko is amazing she
currently has a special which is awesome
it's on it's called the Intruder it is
on HBO Max you gotta check it out she is
one of the most unique interesting and
funny people I've met and talked to and
had the pleasure of watching live in
recent memory and I'm so glad that she
sat down to make it weird if you guys
are uh stand up if you guys are stand-up
comedy fans and you'd like to see me do
stand-up comedy why not come to a show
to a live show the next Largo is a go to
Largo
dashla.com there's always a Largo show
happening the next one I believe yep is
on January 10th there'll be one in
February as well just go to
largo.la.com if you like to come to that
if you don't live in the Los Angeles
area and you'd like to see me I am going
to be next in San Francisco on January
12th followed by Portland Seattle
Atlanta Charlotte and Washington DC we
are going to be adding a bunch more tour
dates I love this new hour I'm loving
taking it on the road always means so
much if weirdos are there links to all
of those are at
petehomes.com super simple super easy
also we only have one pizza pick here up
top and it's one of my absolute
favorites if you're watching the video
I'm pointing to it right now is the
Apollo neuro and if you're like me the
holidays can be stressful I'm one of
those people that gets a little bit
overwhelmed with all of the people all
the presents all the planning all the
parties and I have been swearing and
leaning on my Apollo neuro even more
than I normally do for those of you that
know don't know it's not a watch people
often think it's a watch uh Val wears
hers on her ankle I wear mine on the
inside of my wrist Apollo neuro is a
piece of wearable tech that delivers
soothing gentle vibrations that are
interpreted by your nervous system
basically as a hug it's basically touch
therapy that you wear you barely notice
it in fact you can set it so low that
you definitely won't notice it but your
nervous system responds basically if I
can feel this I must be safe and it is
like wearing a hug it's like wearing
something that can energize you often in
the late afternoon after I pick Leela up
from school I am dragging but I don't
want to drink coffee because it stays in
my system and makes it impossible to
sleep energy and wake up is a setting on
the Apollo that I don't talk about a lot
I usually just mention that it's great
for during workouts which it is but it's
also great when you're just craving
espresso but maybe you don't want to
drink more coffee you put it on energy
and wake up and you start to feel it
getting into your body getting into your
heartbeat and adrenalizing you it is
incredible and an incredible tool for
parents and also just people that need
to avoid that mid-afternoon crash
similarly for the holidays we had a lot
of people over I had it rocking on
social and open I had it on clear and
focused when I was doing this podcast
rebuild and recover is awesome for after
workouts or just stressful situations
like for me after everybody leaves the
party put on rebuild and recover feel
more safe more in control because of
this wearable hug from my nervous system
relax and unwind is awesome for during
flights or at night when you're watching
a movie and you just want to kind of
pre-pre-pre get ready for bed really
helps start lulling your nervous system
into that feeling of security that is
awesome for deep restful sleep and also
when I get in bed I put it on sleep and
renew which as I always mention is a
real game changer not only does it help
you fall asleep but if you get up in the
middle of the night you can just push
the buttons on the Apollo and it'll
re-run the program so if you're having a
hard time like I do sometimes 3 A.M you
wake up you start thinking about the
next day you start getting all
distracted just hit the Apollo it's got
you it's gonna literally lull you back
to sleep tell your body in a language it
can understand you're safe
everything's okay let's go to sleep or
you're safe everything's okay let's
create some energy or you're safe
everything's okay let's meditate there's
also a meditation setting which I
absolutely love I always mention it's
not woo-woo this is not sold in crystal
shops it was developed by a
neuroscientist and a board-certified
psychiatrist who have been studying the
impacts of chronic stress for nearly 15
years and Apollo's effects on stress
sleep cognitive performance and Recovery
have been proven in multiple clinical
trials and real world studies and I'm
saying for me and Val we've had them now
for years I will turn around if I I
recently I told this last time I drove
away from the house realized I didn't
have my Apollo I was 10 minutes away I
turned back it's it's that good it's 30
minutes good I'll go back and get it
because it's that important to my day so
give it a try it's a great way to show
your support of this podcast and it's a
great gift you can give yourself and
your nervous system for 10 off go to
apollonuro.com weird that's APO LL any
url.com weird you'll get 10 off and show
your support of the show which means so
very much all right everybody this is
otsko enjoy make sure to check out his
her special the Intruder and hope to see
you out there on the road
get into it do you want a Magic Mike
okay
here's why
let's start with your hair I'm just
gonna put this here oh cool
um hi hi how do you feel because you you
we're running a little later you okay do
you need a second to like
acclimate oh you know this kind of raw
energy is what I honestly I ran on all
my life can I be real yeah I love it
like I'm always looking like like with
stand up I'm always looking for a way in
yeah yeah yeah now you have this
you were only 10 minutes late which by
the way is that even late hey but you
know in this town I feel like that's
finished a lot of careers or it could it
could no no you're right it depends if
they already they've always waved yeah
you're right people always no people
always wait for you know the star
and not that I'm the star but I'm just
saying that's never been if the crew was
late maybe you're fired I actually I've
heard some stories about people who uh
really come late like four five six
hours on yeah the late you say that when
they're dead James Gandolfini would
sometimes come late like season six
Sopranos yeah the biggest biggest show
in the world right so he would
understandably what I mean is I love the
guy I'm not trying to talk [__] he would
show up late on a Monday because he was
off being James Gandolfini yeah and the
story I heard is that he would just hand
people what like like Tony Soprano he
just hand them like four hundred dollars
like everybody on the crew wow you just
have this assistant give him a brick of
cat to be like sorry go around sorry
sorry wow and then everybody was like
and here I am I didn't even get the
money and I'm spreading uh good PR wow
yeah the money part I hadn't heard yeah
you heard the other part just being late
you did yeah but yeah like isn't I think
the rock is notorious for being late
really two shoots yeah like three hours
you know a rock in a late place that's
nothing no no no hey nothing we're just
warming up
between a rock and a lake place look
it's the one today like we like to say
no yeah gosh I'm so not a puns person I
love I love when I pun I just replaced a
word in a thing yeah it's not it's it's
below when you make a colloquialism up
or something like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I can do that say what say
what you're gonna say no the between
Mariah Carey showed up to her own show
three hours late just like two days ago
you mean to perform just think so to
perform were you there no no no but the
friends of mine were and they were like
they were like look at here I love
Mariah Carey secretly are they what oh
me are these friends you I mean don't we
don't we all love her no yeah you you
don't yeah she's I think about her this
is the season to think about her it's
every December can I say that's part of
it is there a performer that I believe
less when they say all I want for
Christmas is you yeah you're right if
Dolly Parton said it I'd be like maybe
but think of all the people hearing the
song If a Dolly Parton not even Dolly
she's too huge yeah cause Yeah by now
you're like oh you're just you know do
you even do you even feel the words do
you even do you even but I think about
all the people hearing it for the first
time yes or seeing it in the movie Love
Actually for the first time
because that's a movie I don't really
like to go back and watch again it
doesn't age perfectly I'm like oh it was
fine I don't even I just remember like
the cards hey yep I love you and that
doesn't age well yeah why well he kisses
his best friend's girlfriend or his best
friend's wife which I think in Britain
they're just like it's just a homeless
Christmas kiss like it's different it
really is just a little pick yeah all
right that's it so like that's not cool
ah cheating I also find that things so
not today right I don't even because
everybody's open and stuff or do you
just mean no I mean I thought you said
it doesn't age well as in like in 2022.
no I agree gone done I also think
psychologically it's significant that
she's dating a black guy and a white man
is kind of going like I'm not trying to
yeah no I've always said Love Actually
forward in their thinking
that guy but there's like this white guy
going like what about me
reminded me about all the yeah I just I
just remember the cards I don't remember
I just well I'm married to someone I
don't want to say she makes me watch it
every year but okay I watch it every
year you do I'm not saying anyone was
consciously racist or even like hateful
I'm just saying like it's interesting
yeah yeah yeah because I'm the theist of
the movie Love Actually I would say if
this is your dream if the movie is the
dream you're telling me about I'd be
like it's kind of interesting that like
the only black dude in the movie is kind
of a not it's not a full cuckold but
it's like a guy that behind his back is
yeah this love story Brewing that we're
all kind of like
yeah no totally different because if you
flop it around different combinations
would feel different is all I'm saying
no for real yeah that's true that's true
that's good to point out yeah is it or
am I just white splitting no I no you
remind me of the movie so I'm like yeah
that is I am Love Actually explaining
I'll do that I'm actually explaining
I'll take you through so that's what you
watch every year I Valerie who loves you
by the way yeah I'm just saying she's
taking your dance classes so she has a
whole other level right connection yeah
yes I mean like a spiritual bond and is
so I've I've seen you dance on stage a
little bit but she's like
you know yeah mirrored your moves and
stuff and she is completely in awe of
you people have a different connection
to Fitness instructors than comedians
you know that is true there's something
like a like business instructors leaders
you know Sherpas that's what I was gonna
say yes you lead them over a mountain
they don't think they can get through
yeah and on the other side they're I'm
gonna say something crazy why I think
they feel better than people that went
to a comedy show even maybe like if you
get someone dancing and sweating real
hard for 45 minutes sure sure yeah I'd
put that up against laughing really hard
I bet it's the same I yeah I'm starting
to you know fitness instructor is going
down for me and comedy is really like I
was starting to think comedians I take
it back comedians are leaders too of
course we are yeah yes yeah I think that
we I don't mean to really pull I just
realize we are recording this oh my gosh
they should be more oh what more about
it no more ashamed to say we're leaders
but you're literally
a leader you're leading a group in a
certain direction that's that's what
have you seen your comments in DMS you
know hey you brought me out of dark
times come on that's lovely right like
through the pandemic it was and then I
found you or you said this one thing
right yeah yeah the pandemic but yeah
I like to try and get the guests to say
pandemic yeah during the pandemic you
really don't love me yeah yeah when they
say you know yeah and fitness
instructors get that too but it's it's a
little different you know it's about
it's about self like
I don't know maybe it's similar either
way I'm glad I somebody in a power
position meaning they're in front I
don't mean they're actually more
powerful than anybody but they've been
elected to go in front and they're gonna
go like this of all of the many ways is
kind of what we're doing right now yeah
of all the many things you could think
about you could be stagnant you could be
still you could be serious you could be
silly I'll be the thing you can model
right because we go all go through life
mirroring and modeling and reflecting
what's in front of us so you go like hey
I'll be something pleasant for you to
reflect I'll be a different thought
system I'll be a different set of
movements and at the end of it we'll all
be better that's like the promise or the
pledge it's like if you follow me for a
class or a comedy show at the end we'll
feel better I promise and that's what
for me makes it so offensive when I'm
not doing well because I'm like I know
this sounds like insanity but I'm like
don't you know this is for us it's not
just for me to be like
um Captain big [__] I hate to laugh but
a hostile crowd does feel like you're
trying to like steal from them but
really what I'm trying to do is get us
all to hold it it's a rally you're on
the maypole yeah comedy show is rallying
up the the troops I don't you know I
don't know every every time I go to
Comedy stresses I always use War terms
because that's all I know I guess but
yeah you're rallying up you know it's
like a Battle Cry like Hey we're all
weirdos
[Music]
I think that way I think that way too I
feel so wild thinking that way yes
that's it's uh unless alone yes and
you're getting less alone you're very
good being less alone yeah and you know
just your your physicality and what
you're saying and just everything about
you seems to be celebrating your
meanness and that makes me feel by
osmosis I'm like wait and I'm Pete
that's otsuko I'm Pete cool yeah yeah
give me that I'll be this right we can
all be each other it really is kind of
like a Dr Seuss story hopefully yes yeah
I'm done there's a lot of Vibes yeah you
do have Zeus Vibes I think I'm like Zeus
and Lil Jon Vibes do you know little
John Little John is uh he's he's the
hype man that was like yeah
come on you know in all the songs right
email cast yeah yeah no no no no no I
keep insisting little jokes it's okay I
was trying I was trying to be like brush
it over but yeah yeah but I really
shined a big Spotlight on there no I
don't know a little joke he's like a
flavor for this generation
yeah yeah even uh mm-hmm yeah you just
decided to let me off the hook well I'm
trying to think of the did uh Flavor
Flav because I don't know his work as
much besides like how he looked yeah
he's growing up he's now Flavor Flav oh
he's PhD
did he did he like have songs or is it
yeah he was more energy he was the hype
man kind of like a little person that
was in Kid Rock remember him oh we wow I
don't I always knew him as a single
artist so well there was and then there
was another there's there's a joke to be
made here let's let's Let It Go by
there's a smaller person on stage
not the late one okay Kid Rock Kid Rock
and was that The Rock was that kid kid
rock like so there's a smaller person
yeah what did he go by if he I don't
know that guy is already Kid Rock but he
passed I'm gonna let us know wow for the
Riff I want I'd want to know we're going
into a rift Zone yeah yeah
it's good you're with us yes so he was
kind of the Flavor Flav to Kid Rock
Flavor Flav did have one song that I'm
aware of called cold lamp and and it was
just about how he left her relax like he
loved to be lamping that's cool and if
you want to be cool to me yeah not to
anyone else I should listen if I call
you one day and you're like what are you
up to you go just lamping nobody says it
hey just keeping it cool just cold
lamping I'll start lamping if you want
to be cool to me not everyone else but
just me when I call you and I go how are
you feeling how are you feeling Pete
you're gonna go yeah
because I'm like a little John yeah
because that's my flavor flip I
understand and we're actually friends
online you little John me and little
John okay that's a that's a big Chasm
you just jump because the word online is
is like on the other side of the Grand
Canyon you're like we're friends no
online oh he's on the other side of the
Grand Canyon well because we haven't met
in person yet but he was he was even
gonna open my HBO special oh really just
be like yeah yeah everybody come on on
your feet now you know but he didn't uh
he he couldn't make it in time to New
York from Vegas where he has a residency
DJing these days okay and yeah to make
it in time for the taping but anyway
do you talk to one another we talk to
each other we support each other no yeah
how did I get into the hype person
energy but tell me tell me oh that's my
energy on stage hyping people up a
little bit I agree right that's what
you're like a Flavor Flav I'm yeah yes
yeah I'm your Flavor Flav Flavor Flav
and Dr Seuss I don't think there's any
shame in acknowledging that that's
certainly what I'm trying to do what
sucks though not to this isn't a leading
question what sucks sometimes my opener
now these days is I go I'm in a funny
mood which is great because sometimes
I'm not uh-huh you still have to do the
job right and what sucks is when I'm
trying to get a crowd into my energy and
I realize there's actually some static
in my energy meaning maybe I'm a little
stressed today maybe I'm a little under
slept under fed whatever it may be yeah
actually like swirling them up into me
and I'm like wait I'm not I'm not I
don't want to say clean but I'm not
running as smoothly as I'd like to I see
and then I realize I'm a hype man but
I'm not being as Pete homsy as I'd like
to be does that ever happen to you yeah
for sure but then you just sort of rest
in the opposite energy you just own it
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sometimes
I'll just like me be more I'm like this
is a more deadpan show I love that I
just gotta it but it's still the same
silliness it's still the you know
because the words themselves will help
you they'll carry you into this yeah
yeah the jokes themselves will still be
the jokes it's just like a more dead pan
uh what they're gonna laugh about is the
more just like that aspect the silliness
the actual jokes right you know they
won't get the full like Dynamic aspect
of it but that's fine that's right yeah
I love hearing you say that because
there's certain shows Val will be in the
audience for example yeah and I'll be
like I just couldn't find myself in the
way that I want to yeah and she was like
no one noticed like right and I just
need that's the best thing a partner can
do is just go like everyone was loving
it like yeah sometimes I'm just battling
this idea of how it's in fact I'm often
battling an idea of how it's supposed to
be yeah instead of surrendering to what
it is yeah and not just on stage I know
my life and you're really battling your
past performances you're only seeing the
past yeah and you so you so it's like
it's that's still a challenge for me you
have to like erase even the show you
just did an hour ago yes and try to like
be right there and then or else it's
yeah you're you're comparing yourself to
a former you it's like that no one can
find you you're gonna just get upset
while you're on stage I mean like that
joke landed differently last time well
you're bringing up why I hate to do two
shows in the same night I hate it
because it's not because
I could tell you oh my voice gets sore
my body's or whatever it is or I get
confused have I done this joke it's not
even that it's just that every joke I do
yeah even if it does exactly as well I'm
still going like I'm like the pencil
like same as last one
um better than last one
worse than like the whole way through oh
and that is a not always yeah but it
takes all this conscious effort right so
sometimes I'll disrupt and I'll I won't
do my opener I'll play that game you
ever play this game like try not to open
for like do your opening joke for as
long as you can and just like [__]
around oh interesting or be a silly
Billy oh yes yes yes yes for sure for
sure because you're just like I don't
want to do the hit these things right
now yeah yeah you're just like [__] it
because yeah you start to feel like a
door-to-door Salesman nothing wrong with
the door to door salesman but yeah but
that raw energy is like why we got into
it right like that fun keeping it fun
for us is so important totally yeah
which is funny because the raw energy
that you're talking about is so like
you're talking about you coming right
coming in wild hair different hair than
usual different dhtu it's freeing it is
freeing does it have to be like oh it's
not a precise bowl cut right no mistake
seen anywhere dude to like oh or is
there flyaways I don't give a [__] you
know that's oh by the way That's how
little John would say it I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] I'm gonna say
that he's not pronunciated no for sure
for sure lots of people just throwing
that around for sure I'm obsessed
obviously like I think about him way too
much but especially I don't know why I
keep referring because with a hype man
who is he the hype man for
everybody his life yeah he's life's
hyped man yeah I do know the song that
goes shot shot shot shot shot shot
everybody that's him too okay
so we listen to different songs I know
we do I don't listen to anything it's
not a problem I listen to like dry
lectures about God I'm like my card is
going it's good profound right
back yes because it constantly made it
back to you boys yes I was yes don't
don't I won't do it don't get derailed
yeah I won't I won't I just I love I
love music tell me everything no so I
really think there are music people and
then there are non-music people and I
I'm saying this the most honest thing I
can say yeah I envy yeah we can talk
about that okay I envy the music people
so hard people who are like really into
music I'm not like that I don't I okay
yeah I was just saying a general I like
music because you know most of all of us
do we do but I'm not I don't have
records being like oh you oh you like
the sounds of the file no no no but you
love it yeah I listen to like two types
of music that's it what are they yeah
John yeah hip hop and that would be like
modern hip-hop you're not listening to
old school yeah and some might even say
he's just a voice okay so we have that
are you sponsored well they are
sponsored but it's because I love them
okay cool you would love and then they
sponsor and my friend developed it but
yeah we had that talk look at you
yeah that's called playing ball right
there I love that yeah I picked mine
yeah it's yes and I'm very yes and hype
energy yeah I believe it do more stress
less but let me see what you were saying
yeah guess you hold it up like a
commercial I love it we were remember we
were upstairs at The Improv and we had
to talk about what we do before shows
right well this is this is what I do
before shows because it's it it has
adaptogens to smooth out stress but a
little bit of caffeine and a little bit
of neurotropic to help you think I
guarantee that's awesome I'm gonna love
it yeah you drink it I'm gonna drink it
oh yeah because I'm telling you to
because a lot of people just put it down
oh really yeah oh no I am so curious I
was like oh I'm a little thirsty what's
this you know and that's how you got me
you knew we would get there quenching
well there's also water on the ground
yeah oh oh wow this is truly this is
truly tasty and oh my God and it really
it did hit it kind of hit because I
this is truly taking two camera people
that are just listening to this are like
what is happening well she's literally
like mugging out to the camera I'm
tasting yeah drink that well just shoot
it it's like a shot you don't have to no
can I take the tiny sips I wanna I want
it to last and so that would be awesome
I'm a baby Pete I'm different I'm I'm Dr
Seuss Yes Energy too your eyes can't
lose yeah that's right that's me
oh thank you for remembering he quoted
something I quoted that I said before
the past I'm only seeing the past so we
were saying though we're on a lot of
things we're on music yeah oh yeah yeah
so where are you on music in the present
do you have any opinions about yourself
that you just don't like this is one of
them anything I'm at peace with it okay
but like I'm married you're married yeah
one of the things that I see Val see
when we talk about the vulnerability of
a relationship yeah because I'm like I'm
Gonna Let You in I let a lot of people
in with the podcast but she sees it it's
different from hearing someone talk
about it but what it is is the opinion
that I don't necessarily like about
myself but I've made my peace with is
that I'm just not a music person oh I
don't throw it on and go like are you
[__] kidding me I'm like it all
pretty much sounds the same to me I
agree okay yeah and what what is that oh
because you found the ones that don't
aren't that way for you
you mean what do you mean like I yeah so
I don't most like anything with guitar
yeah I'm like oh yeah it's like that I
put it in the same category okay it's a
guitar song If it's like hip-hop dance
so I might know a little bit more about
yeah but I'm not like turn turn dance on
I'm not like at a party being like oh
you don't know good music like I think
that tends to be you know what
audiophiles you know can be a little
controlling uh sorry and but you're
saying music just kind of you're not
you don't have like playlists Pete's
playlists for Monday Tuesday Wednesday
this is it okay if you put
okay so I love movies film
um film uh-huh film yeah is so I don't
like photography either I don't just go
around and look at photography okay it's
not like I don't get it yeah but film is
photography
and acting and comedy and drama and
music so I'm watching White Lotus and
I'll go Jesus [__] this music is
incredible right but it's part of the
experience when I go to a concert
everyone's heard me say this before and
then they're just playing music I'm like
it would be great if anything else was
happening like I'm just I feel like an
idiot just sitting there being like
which is why people are getting [__]
up like they love drugs they don't love
you they love drugs they're getting
drunk outside yeah but just sitting
there and being like yeah that doesn't
mean I haven't had some great concerts I
have for sure but even my favorite bands
I'm like you know yeah I'd rather uh
hear this song in a great movie then I
was saying I'd really have something it
feels like part of the part of the pizza
it's not the full Pizza yes that's right
so these are like crust people or you
could say they're cheese people they
just love cheese I'm like I love cheese
when it's on bread with tomato sauce
yeah yeah that's a movie or that's life
then there's great performers who know
entertainers I think there's like
artists and then there's entertainers
some are both I hear you and
entertainers who get that about people
and so they're a musician but they'll
make sure to have multi-dimensional
aspects to their show agree so there's
films happening yes The Flaming Lips are
coming out in a giant ball and like
rolling all over the audience and that
sort of stuff yeah spectacle yeah or
maybe even like a video that they've
made or there's projections and it's
part of they interact with it or
something well there's a story arc the
national put out one of their the
Nationals is my favorite band they put
on their albums with a short film that
had all the and it was a a dancer I
looked you because you're a dancer who
is pretending to be a baby and then
pretending to be a toddler and we had
the music going through it yeah and then
all the way through her death and you're
watching it and you're just like
yeah absolutely devastated I was like
that's what I'm talking about yes yes I
love that album I'll play it in the car
I play it constantly in the car and I
like it but like I love it
but I see other people loving it just on
its own the crust people yes people just
love crust and I envy it because I'm
like these people are bringing their own
internal cheese and tomato sauce into it
and I can't be bothered yeah I'm not
that available I I can't find that in me
so easily I'll also say one last thing
and I really only want to hear from you
is that no this is interesting to me
because I usually Drive in silence and
people are like what and I don't have
the words to describe what I'm feeling
and maybe this is it I about music if
I'm not listening to uh a lecture or
something like that I love to drive in
silence and I also love to drive to
instruments I listen to a lot of
instrumental
post-rock kind of like stuff that's just
sound that just like white noise it's
better than white noise it's beautiful
music but it's not it doesn't I don't
really see I don't like shot shot shot
shot it's like why are you imposing your
experience why is it Saturday night 3
A.M in Vegas in my car because it's 11
A.M and I'm trying to think about what I
would say to my dad in like a moment of
honesty or whatever it may be sure I'm
trying to think that thing
right right yeah yeah he's trying to be
still
sometimes I do need to get out of uh I
I'm like oh I do like to think and I'm
always I'm such a workaholic I think and
so that's why silence driving in silence
doesn't matter because I'm usually like
writing a joke or something yeah writing
a joke I agree I never have thoughts
about what to write to my dad or
something because that's too sad for me
so if I get into those feelings
shots shots shots yeah yeah there's a
general set a General sadness constantly
around me I think I understand yeah so
I'm always trying right away yeah run
away yeah yeah I understand that's why I
listened to Wild music or like beautiful
dance hall music island sounds
um but you know the national it'll be
like it yeah it can be unless I'm me and
my husband are in the con going I
remember that one song by the national
was great we'll put it on and we'll have
fun singing it I wanna hurry home to you
another okay that was a sad time yeah
slow show and I'll have to turn it off
but yeah it's it's very tell me about
the status only because I love it if you
don't like talking about it let's not
yeah no no no I like
I'm looking to come down is a big part
you're looking to go up always oh I'm
looking to go down interesting always so
you wake up like feel good like that you
wake up feel good yeah old homes he's
running like we were talking about Mike
Birbiglia like two drink Mike I'm too
coffee P like I wake up to coffee and
I'm I'm already going so like that's why
I like Radiohead like I want to like
lower frequencies like get get grounded
get Earth no Black Eyed Peas tell me
what it is you know you know songs I do
not know something I just remember you
know people from my time exactly two
questions we're gonna get into that
sadness uh for because it's interesting
but is there anything that as a married
person because I told you I don't love
that Val sees that I am not into music
is there anything that sharing your life
with somebody you're like get out of
here you're seeing this weird thing
about me no I want him them to see
everything right I love being married I
love having a best friend you know I'm
oh I want him to know everything like
I'll update him when I'm on the toilet
you know sure because I just need him to
know what I'm thinking and I don't know
if I I don't have a therapist but and I
I think other people would probably be
like hey that's not healthy
what I'm saying I talk about this all
the time we're aware of codependency
like I I hear that I guess the the
question a therapist might ask is what
would it feel like if he wasn't there
you know it's nice to have him there but
is it is it like a need does it become a
thing where like and is it him or is it
somebody no interest that's the
dangerous question no for sure yeah we
don't even know that I got two real for
me yeah where I was like oh wow yeah oh
um have you always been that way in your
other relationships well I always like
let's share everything oh gosh no I
guess not yeah I wasn't like that and so
I found a special person yeah it is him
and I love doing everything with him and
yeah but I am like chaos go you know you
gotta do some things on your own you can
go to some shows by yourself you know
you're not a solo person yeah I go like
he even comes to a lot of almost all my
shows even just spots around town and
you know yeah
um I want to let him live too but he's
like I also enjoy this so right what are
we to do we're obsessed with each other
and so there isn't there isn't anything
that like he sees that I can think of
that I feel bad about because I'm like
yeah that's me like yeah no that's
beautiful and and don't misunderstand me
yeah I don't actually have shame right
there's part of me that's kind of like
you have to I this is this is odd I
watch the whole planet being like I
don't even I can't even do an impression
of it but they're like have you heard
the new Bieber song I don't even know
what they're saying I'm in the corner
going like you [__] care and Val has
to uh uh she sees it so is there
anything that you're like I know the
world is like this but look you're my
you're my partner and you're gonna see I
don't like this or I really like this
yeah anything like that
gosh I guess what I'm asking it's much
simpler what's weird about you right
right right yeah
um
gosh I mean you know I've been I I've
always tried to be so normal
all my life so is that facts huh yeah
don't we all want to be so normal yeah
but you're a funky chunky monkey I know
I understand
you're a funky joke I'm Green Eggs and
Ham you are green eggs and ham oh yeah I
know when I say strange you understand
this podcast is a celebration of
weirdness yes I do and that's what I
love yes yeah I don't understand did you
used to not be the way you are right now
because you look like yeah safari
hunting hats like you just got out of
the wind blew in it and I got a cute
perm out of it yeah exactly but haven't
you always been
not blending in with the group yeah
that's true but I thought that uh
sometimes you know there were time
phases where I was like I'll bleach my
hair and I will wear at least to fit in
yeah yeah to not fit in oh to fit in
yeah to look more Anglo-Saxon yes yeah
really and then it did that sounds kind
of sad it was kind of sad it's sad it's
kind of opposite it did the opposite
because it highlighted my face even more
so I look at her it was like look at
this Asian face even more so it did the
opposite and it was I couldn't bleach it
blonde enough so it was like orange so I
just stood out even more which is very
which to me that's Japanese punk rock
right there I think you bleach the hair
but it comes out orange that looks cool
to me oh that's cool you're gonna have
your suspenders around your oh yeah kind
of like a leopard because I grew up
loving punks so like the Japanese and
that it's funny if people were into
Japanese punk when you know I was trying
to fit in in 2006 that would have been
cool yeah I would have thought you were
cool oh thanks yeah let's go back in
time and you can meet a young boy in a
rayon shirt and acid wash jeans with wet
hands I would be like hey I see you I
know what you're trying to do and I'm
like thanks like it wasn't an accident
get out of here man boobs
no not at all I wanted everyone to feel
a part of something and yeah and so I'm
trying to fit in with with where was it
a predominantly white school is am I
hearing you right no it's it was pretty
diverse but the the white uh the
swimmers were the jocks and they happen
to be white and so it was just like whoa
like they're so cool and that's where
all the money was put in I feel like
whoever the jog star is where the school
puts money into the most so it's not
it's not always football it's always
cheerleading I think that's a
misconception yeah you know some schools
it's uh lacrosse like the DC high
schools lacrosse is where they put the
money into so it's like the rich people
who are able to I was just gonna say
well swimming yeah the reason why a lot
of people from the inner city are good
at basketball is because there are
basketball hoops in the inner city not a
lot of pools not a lot of the Cross
Fields that's true a lot of golf courses
you know what I mean so yeah you're
right there's a status yes or not status
we attribute status to it but there's
money Associated to this right right and
those are not being the cool people I my
school was the same way I I don't
remember being in awe of the swim team
but it was like they're like it is sort
of magical like you spend like a third
of your day in water like I know I know
no yeah mythical creature I know they
float they're very sure of themselves
and they yes and they're all wearing
swimsuits and not feeling weird about it
yeah of course they were but in my high
school I just assumed they were like
because in the yearbook there's a photo
there's a group photo of them all in
their swimsuits and I'm like I'd rather
die yeah I'd rather die yeah in fact
give me a one piece I'd like the cover
yeah you're like okay self-assurance
exactly how did that come from yeah and
so I've never been asked like what makes
me weird I I so many things yeah I talk
like this and like like I have a weird
Cadence I have weird Cadence which makes
me more of a I think physical performer
but you it's you know when I'm audio
only you can still tell everything I
mean and my jokes and stuff but I think
watching me live does complete the
performance because I do rely on both to
you're a movie of Tom the theater
yeah when I meaning it it's not perfect
as a record unless you'd like to imagine
like imagine what she's doing that made
that funny if you're able to do the you
know adding of the ketchup and stuff
that you were talking about that's right
right or the marinara sauce and yeah
right that's cool fried pizza with
ketchup sure incredible terrible schools
well when I you and I did Largo together
you were telling me that like you're
cold yes tell me that again yeah I have
to reheat that anecdote for for the show
no I thought it was so interesting
because I was talking about how you're
funnier because of how you move and so
many of us forget to move right right
and you don't and you don't need to move
but even if you're a deadpan performer
and then I said I like to like use all
of my body to perform even when I'm just
yeah from my toes I put energy from my
toes all the way to my ankles all the
way up my legs and all the way up my
back I make sure to talk from my stomach
diaphragm and and all of that gives me
enough energy and I was saying I don't
know if it's because I have a borderline
anemia or what poor circulation my
acupuncturist says you know that to
always keep my feet warm but all of it
helps me even not just stand while I'm
performing but just gives me the full
potential you know so it's there if I
need it you're like when I'm performing
your feet yeah it goes all the way up
even if I decide my performance Isn't So
quote unquote physical if it's just
gonna mostly be in the eyes right that's
how I'm gonna deliver most of my punch
lines or something
I still need that full energy potential
like an anchor yeah yeah who taught you
this where did you learn this I don't
know you run into a magical rabbit
I'm like maybe I should be tapped into
my into my body like embodied I want to
say it's some it's rooted in
uh theater a little bit this Japanese
theater one of my roommates
a few years ago was like a teacher and I
forget Shimizu method maybe uh where he
always talked about feet a lot and and
it's what there's a joke to me
let's just keep going he was always
talking about Fusion to me no you're
gonna have pictures of your feet I think
it was just like a he loved the culture
he loved Japan but his you know his name
was Cameron
nothing weird about this dude at all I
think he just wanted to hook up with me
but you know it really hit me I I took
what I took away from it was yeah you
know you can learn from someone who has
a crush on you yeah totally they're very
attentive yes they are okay so this guy
he would always and then he would show
me his training and it would be it would
start with a lot of stomping and I don't
know walking on tippy toes so a lot of
feet stuff
you know what I mean I do and then and
then he would also have to perform lines
while he's doing this and I was watching
us uh you know really there was just it
was very energetic and I was like I
wonder how that would be like if I try
to translate into stand-up comedy I
don't know if it's really interesting
yes go ahead and I'm also a dancer so I
know that all of that I think it's
that's part of the
somewhere some of where that knowledge
comes from too yes yeah that's great
yeah I I I'm not surprised that it
informed one and form the other that
that you watch most stand-ups or that's
a leading question do you ever go like
why aren't these people moving more
because sometimes we're just heads on on
stands and the stand is fun yeah but
that's a that but you know you got to do
you that's your you you move around a
little bit I move a little bit Yeah I
moved more once I moved to LA and the
stages are bigger in New York you're
literally like standing on a cocktail
table like yeah you can't move here
because it's flooding too and so you
have to you had to find Higher Ground I
I saw Mike we were talking about Mike
earlier Mike did do that at one of the
shows in like a City Winery in New York
or something where it did start flooding
really and yeah there was a leak in the
ceiling or something and so he was
literally standing on
the picture you painted I literally saw
a New York comedian do is that what I'm
saying uh-huh I don't know why but Mike
is
in in his core a comedian that should be
standing on a table as the room fled yes
it just feels right to me he's accident
prone
he he would tell you the same yes he's
always I've seen him just fall and trip
on nothing so many times just touring
with him I don't understand I didn't
know you toured with him yeah I toured
with him while I was on my own tour so
we I would go back and forth wow so it
was like double the cities and it was
really fun and that's how we got really
close as friends
um but yeah he was he was always
tripping uh and falling he I had seen
him fall backwards and a whole painting
uh like fall
and like strange like a Priceless work
of arts yeah Picasso
that's a great impression oh my God you
really truly embodied him yes this is
very physical he is very physical he's
like a c he's like he is actually very
physical but like it's so wild because
his delivery is also so calm yeah you
know when it comes to stand up and then
so yeah I think about him all the time
and how I could be more physical I just
think about him all the time as like a
standard I'm like maybe the next special
I do I'll try and do it as well as Mike
doesn't I actually I prefer I would say
this Mike is one of my dearest friends
we talk he's the only friend I have that
we talk at least once a week and I was
talking to him yesterday and I would
have said this to him I do prefer my
slap Dash style it's not as predictable
and it's not as yes beautiful and
there's a reason why it's not on
Broadway it's not consistent in that
same way and I love what Mike is doing
but there it's a conscious choice that
sounds like I could do it but I'm not
even trying to do it his way because I'd
rather be a blubbering guy that's just
like I don't know and like that's what
you're known for that's exactly I agree
that's so you yeah that's what I want to
do yeah so even when I'm saying like oh
maybe I could tighten the laces and
nothing like tight but like but be a
beautiful precious stone that you know
Tom Hanks comes and whenever I talk to
him she's like telling me the amazing
people that are there yeah yeah because
you refined it
right I'm over here being like or you
can go in the corner of this bar and
watch me peanuts it's very different
it's very different styles and it's very
different you know stand-up comedy the
way you do it the way I I do it yeah
where do you fall it seems like you fall
closer to me but yeah I could see you
doing I like arcs and so I try to reach
one you know we always shoot her and
yeah yeah there's a through line yeah
but we all do even if it's like you know
when you come up with an hour it's a
it's coming from the same person yeah so
it'll always have an arc I agree it'll
just be whatever you know uh what is it
called
order order put the jokes in it always
makes sense see I I'm more of that get
out of your own way meaning if I tell
you my dream last night I don't have to
analyze it yeah by virtue of it being my
dream you'll be like I think Pete's mom
was Santa Claus
your own meaning on it yeah so it's like
a little bit but I don't know
because it's my mom being said yeah I
loved that image okay now I'm back I
remember talking to your husband I want
to talk more about your husband and I
want to talk more about what makes you
weird uh but don't don't you have Mom
stuff
uh-huh yes Mom stuff like Mom issues
yeah yeah what's going on there is this
something you talk about yes yeah my mom
has schizophrenia and yeah doesn't your
husband's mom also have schizophrenia
right right yeah I mean yeah we're twins
we're best friends we it was very
important to us that that was the thing
in our significant other no but like
okay can I say
wouldn't is it something you didn't know
you wanted but now that you have it
you're like of course I would want
someone who knows what it's like to have
someone in their family that has
schizophrenia especially a mother for
sure for sure yeah it's such a it was
such a freak situation because I don't
know how many people even what's the
percentage of people that have that and
then what's the percentage of people
that you know have that in common right
Mom Mom both moms how did you guys meet
and then also you you're attracted to
each other right Val and I talk about
that all the time it's like what it
because you have best friend happy
marriage me too best friend happy
marriage what are the chances that the
person who psychologically spiritually
right emotionally matches me absolutely
perfect and if we're being real and we
laugh about this all the time the reason
we got together was hubba hubba yeah
like what a [__] Dingus it's like the
universe was like this is what he needs
pour it in this and yeah look at this
and these big boobies and this and all
that stuff
and then it's like psych and it is your
partner yes that's yeah that happened
it's so wild when does that happen never
yeah go no I know I think about it all
the time yeah we talk about it all the
time too and so yeah uh we but you know
the commonality of both of us having
moms of schizophrenia we didn't realize
till like our third date with each other
and so we were already having fun it was
like oh my gosh you're so hot and oh wow
like we really banter well together and
you know laugh laugh laugh laugh laugh
laugh and then you know these are all in
porn right people who have the same
values the same way of looking at the
world and how they treat people right
yes that it's like it's that's why I'm
like you did a dinner date when people
are like yeah we just had dinner it's
like it's so hard to tell just someone
being like my favorite color is blue and
oh blue is warmest color speaking of you
know like I don't know how dates Go I
mean you love sexy sex
I don't know I don't know how dinner
dates go I understand what you're saying
it just feels like you don't get to see
them out and about in the world like
that's so important
um I just like well we met on a film
shoot so I got to see how he treats the
crew and stuff like that and you know
and at work I just feel like that shows
the whole person more than hey you know
watching them struggle to cut steak and
a dimly lit restaurant which is I feel
like most dates yeah and the force
sitting across from each other my friend
Oren when I was dating when I was single
yeah don't don't go to dinner stop going
to dinner yeah too much pressure it is
you're sitting across from them stiffly
yeah talk about in my ACT I go like
hungry Brothers It's same same answer
it's because it's like Zoom it is you're
a front-facing person Suddenly It's a
[__] but we're a dynamic person with
profiles and backs and yes you know yes
yeah it's like so you met him in the in
the real world this is a movie you were
in I was helping my friend produce a a
film and he was acting in it and so we
met and so it was cool because it's like
there's a work and all kinds of people
there I got to see his talent at the
same time yeah at the same time don't
you dare let me interrupt you at the
same time yeah you were saying at the
same time oh at the same time no no at
the same time yeah like the hubba hubba
or whatever yeah see I'm glad we got
that hubba hubba thank you I think a lot
of uh our friends wardrobe people hair
makeup people
um these are some of our closest friends
and there's a lot of uh flirting I'm
talking about appropriate flirting I'm
not even this has never been my style
I've never been like a little bit so
like that's not my thing cigarette
Martini it's 6 a.m hey how's it going
but there is a lot of relationships that
form on set and I think see if you
follow me here uh not not intellectually
but if you agree with me
there's just a lot of Creative Energy
there's a lot of energy moving around
yes meaning
and I I I'm not trying to be crass here
but like
there's something about creation that is
sexual or you could say sex is creative
meaning yeah I see why the lines get
blurred we're all on set we're all
making something and there's something
about literally birthing a project
birthing a performance birthing a moment
and we're all pointing to the same
there's something it's not just sex it's
love it's not just sex it's love right
it's an aspect of it but it's creativity
it's agreement yeah there's something
about being in an environment where
everyone's agreeing to do the same thing
yeah flying under the same banner and in
that beautiful safe Avatar Village space
people fall in love that's so true
that's why yes that's why God made Adam
and Eve naked you know because he was in
that energy right it's sure it's the
Creative Energy everything's falling in
place that's right a naked person is
more like a tree you know what I mean
because the tree is naked yes I put
pants on my trees
all the trees have pants on because I'm
not a pervert I'm glad I have shirts on
the girl ones the guy ones can be
McConaughey they're topless shirts
because you want to be respectful yeah
yeah or at least a bra uh-huh yeah some
of my trees have bras yeah that is
creativity sexuality love
what we often just classify those as is
like those positive life-giving life
force emotions and we don't have a lot
of places where we're like that your
shows are that way too of course he
wants to come of course I love Val comes
you see this like this Alchemy the whole
audience comes in like a swarm of bees
and and we're and you're a b too and you
get it all going in a circle and the
bees are so happy and you're one of them
and you just go around in a circle
together yeah that feels like
the solar system I know I sound insane
no the whole thing is just the sexy sexy
story very exciting yeah and gosh yeah
how why don't more shows and you know
orgy
or a mass marriage Mass marriage now
stand up and turn to your left and
someone's like why is
my whole life
person on my right now I'm marrying this
guy
yeah yeah I I think any transference of
energy can have a life affirming quality
and those are
places where people people's hearts open
yes because life is being affirmed and
creativity is life-affirming so I'm not
surprised tell me how you met yes yes
that's how we met and then we saw more
of the real world who has two out we
just I think oh I I did I I messaged
Hannah and just was full like boobs out
oh yeah I sent him you did not I sent
him a picture I you did not that he
didn't ask for you need to tell me
everything that's true I was like that
yeah you did not yeah I just was like
hey yeah just like a picture of me
without my my shirt on like a tree
unlike your tree
so but you did ask him out yeah yeah fun
yeah yes and you went out while the
production was still going because I
just want to file this with HR so no of
course yeah no yeah it was still
happening yeah yeah and then we did we
went out and then you know it was it was
fun oh I think we just like immediately
I don't know started hooking up or
something we weren't we weren't like
looking for a husband and wife yes you
know yeah so we were just trying to have
fun it was chasing fun feelings chasing
fun feelings your new book yeah yes it
is so when I started casually it was
like it was like a casual thing and then
it was very evident right away that we
were like yeah hibbly yeah oh wow okay
and was it like that in the past with
other relationships what that that you
you just meet somebody and be looking
for fun feelings and then end up dating
them yeah I suppose but not like with
Val I'm not just trying to make it extra
special but that night like I remember
yeah it was very we were very close
right away okay the first night we met
for example yeah we were going out to
drinks we held hands oh thank you yeah
that is very cute yeah and we held oh no
no we held hands this way uh-huh as a
joke not as oh I'm sorry okay you are
very funny because it's not this for
those should we just describe it to the
not intertwined right just like this
like you like I hold my hand with my
daughter like like you're uh like you're
like a child or yes or when you've won
something no no that's not true like a
handshake yes like is that yeah it's
more like a handshake it's like it's
like a graduation handshake wow that's
amazing that you remember that I'm sure
you commented on that she brings it she
goes remember when we met you held my
hand like this I'm like will you lead it
alone
um okay so you started hooking up and
then when did you have your uh oh
feeling not uh oh but like yeah who boy
I think this is my special person oh
yeah I think I had a certain date sort
of date was when we were out this is
where Mom mom came in yeah mom came in
yeah we found out that you were saying
sorry sorry oh no no so I was over at
his place and then we uh we're about to
have sex again and then for the second
time that day
if I'm showing any aggression it's
because I'm very insecure but it's like
I'm reading from my diary or something
and so that's what you were saying
we were in between bouts of sex yeah I
know I'm just like showing off here no I
wouldn't say it like that like oh you
know yo we're all day
everybody
I know that song
it is Little John yes like a hype man
he's like a Flavor Flav he's a residency
there you go hey he's great this is how
you're gonna this is gonna be your Alibi
exactly one day like I have to pretend
you have enough information about little
John that if you needed to be in Vegas
it could be one of the things you were
at that's true you always if you're
going to be a dishonest person have an
in-residency show I guess in your back
pocket because you can always be like I
was at Penn and Teller and yes you could
have been right good Alibi yeah was it
David Copperfield that alibi has worked
for 15 minutes that was a viable
okay so you were about to do it yeah and
then he took a phone call from his
mother
which was wild and I'd never seen anyone
do that before you know not that I'm
like the hottest person in the world but
I'm also like hey I'm like
um I'm here can I say something yeah
yeah you know there's a movie where this
happens which movie
Love Actually oh my God again please
repaint I love actually for me that's
what this is this is a re-watch Love
Actually podcast you're reminding me
again I only remember the cards yes
Laura is it Laura Linney Laura Linney
has a schizophrenic brother what and
she's about to have sex with the love of
her life that she's been obsessed with
and they're about to do it and her phone
rings whoa and she answers it because
it's a schizophrenic brother [__]
what's happening oh my gosh that's so
wild it's crazy and then does she get to
have sex it's ruining her life oh no
that's the whole plot in fact I'm pretty
sure I've seen it every year I should
know I'm pretty sure they don't get
together it's one of the sad ones oh my
gosh right it's one of the they don't
get together because she can't he keeps
it's very movie schizophrenia meaning
I'd love to hear what it's actually like
but in the movie it's very like
schizophrenia actually
so dumb please don't one all your
comments are gonna go
yeah
I always wanted to win this and when I
oh I want to shake the hands like you
held your wife's hand that way
surprisingly cold I think I'm dead no
I'm very cold oh my gosh
your toes I know please your
acupuncturistic you're like could you
just light yourself on fire yeah like
warm your toes yeah a very Chilly Willy
so the schizophrenic actually oh but
he's like uh my nurses are trying to
kill me there's a I think there's a
sniper on the roof okay and he
occasionally tries to hit her it's a
very sad part of the movie wow does that
yeah he answered his mom yeah because it
was love actually but he talked to wow
that's amazing yes he talked to her for
like an hour yeah like comforting her in
ways that maybe Laura Lindy was doing
regular bed just wait yeah I was baking
I was or I was being cooked like a
microwave yeah uh just spinning basking
and a weird UV light that surrounded his
room is this how you found out were you
listening and like this sounds like when
I talk to my mom yes yeah yeah and I was
like oh this is so interesting yeah I
wonder well she was distressed from
something you know I couldn't hear her
voice so I didn't know but I was and
then he started singing to her and I was
like huh I've done that like shots yeah
um I think where does he sing to her I
think it was Hey Jude yeah the Beatles
it's it's actually a uh
for listeners out there who are
experiencing Hey Jude is actually a very
soothing song for folks with you know at
least schizophrenia it works for my mom
too yeah yeah yeah take with food
I don't know what it is because then it
just goes into no no no no no no no no I
don't know it's just like a really cool
song just remembered it I think there's
like a um like uh what is it om quality
to it I agree does that make sense
frequency and that's what the Beatles
are all about yeah you realize that
George Harrison song yeah just has Hari
Krishna in the background that's right
well like why is yeah but you don't
because you're just like this is a great
song they're literally chanting in the
background yes yes yeah yeah but it
calms you yeah so by the way you have to
pitch this as a movie this is an
incredible movie the sex just the sex
part just the sex part yeah like a
hardcore adult film
no no I mean
it's incredible you meet the love of
your life
then you're about to do it there's a
great scene he takes a phone call for an
hour all right and we show in real time
of course most of the movie is the phone
call all and that's the whole budget is
paying Paul McCartney for Hey Jude
the whole budget that would be awesome
but like watching you realize like oh my
God this guy also has a schizophrenic
parent right how did you feel what did
what was going through your mind yeah it
was kind of it's cool it's like I saw
his childhood you know it's like I
immediately knew how he grew up too and
when I told him that that was my
mother's situation I feel like he felt
the same way wow and I was like oh
everything clicked like of course we're
making each other laugh and we put
levity first and we care about other
people's feelings and you know our
compassionate and you know even
remembering like when we went out to eat
like him being bugged when someone was
being shitty to a waiter and I'm like
yeah like you know The Human Condition
You know it's just like it just made
sense even just though we've only had
like two dates before that wow I was
like oh yeah it's cooking because we
were raised the same hypersensitive it's
almost like being that sensitive was a
survival this necessity yeah yeah let's
let's talk more about this we're gonna
write a sweet Zone being a magic mind
well we're going to go to the mid roles
and we'll be back in two minutes and I
want to keep talking about your husband
and and we'll get into some of this the
reality of of parents with schizophrenia
yeah very interesting okay we'll be
right back
pardon the interruption weirdos for the
water that otsuko and I are drinking go
to
nirvanawatersciences.com and you can use
promo code Pete 20 for 20 off it is
incredible Muscle Recovery
like bodybuilding body recovery water
our sponsors today are better help
Today's Show is brought To Us by our
friends at betterhelp when you're at
your best you can do great things for
those of you that are listening to this
podcast for a long time you know that
talk therapy has literally changed and
perhaps even saved my life certainly
saved the correction the course
correction that I needed uh to live the
best life that I could possibly live and
I'm a huge huge believer in talk therapy
but sometimes your life bogs you down
you may feel overwhelmed or you're not
showing up in the way that you want to
but talk therapy is here to help as I
always say it is greater than the sum of
its parts it seems like you're just
talking to somebody but when that
somebody is a trained licensed
professional and they know how to guide
and to nudge and to get you going deeper
into better and better and more
meaningful discoveries it is a game
changer and literally a life changer and
better help is here to make it so so so
much easier so if you're thinking of
giving therapy a try better help is a
great option it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online just fill
out a brief questionnaire and get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch you can even switch therapists if
you don't feel the vibe switch at no
additional charge at any time so you can
feel more empowered more balanced and
get everything sort of sorted and in its
proper place enabling you to have the
2023 that you want that give yourself
that best foot forward by cleaning
things up internally which is where most
things are happening and do it with some
help if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can help get you
there visit betterhelp.com weirdo today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo show your
support of the show show yourself some
love show your brain some support show
your emotion some support and watch your
work your relationships everything just
in general flourish that's what it did
for me and better help is here to make
it so easy no no traffic no weird
waiting rooms nothing awkward just you
and a therapist are so close thanks to
better help go to betterhelp.com
weirdo for 10 off your first month also
we are brought To Us by our friend
rocket money formerly known as true bill
if your New Year's goals are to manage
your budget better and to save money you
seriously need rocket money it's the
best way to hack your finances in the
New Year rocket money like I said
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place I'm
one of those people that I get a little
paranoid I get freaked out knowing and
it's facts knowing that there things
that I signed up for subscribe for that
I'm not using just these tiny sometimes
they're small sometimes they're big but
let me tell you they add up these un
these benign sort of Splinter Cell
subscriptions that are somewhere deep in
your finances that if you knew about
them you would get rid of them but you
don't know about them and that's where
rocket money is here to help over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
they forgot about 80 that's like that
streaming service that you don't watch
that you bought just to watch one show
on I know which one it was for me and
that free trial that they they tricked
you into that automatically recurs every
third day 30 days but you're not even
using it rocket money will go in as your
Advocate quickly and easily identify the
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want
rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button simply find the subscription
they're like what the heck is that that
you don't recognize click cancel and
Rocket money will cancel it for you you
no more long hold times with customer
service or being tricked into staying on
for some reason or tedious emailing back
and forth companies typically aren't
very responsive when you're trying to
kick their butt to the curb but rocket
money takes care of that for you over 3
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720 a
year
what do you mean it adds up 720 bucks a
year is the average savings with rocket
money so stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com weird that's
rocketmoney.com weird rocketmoney.com
that one had three times I'm gonna say
it four times just to rocketmoney.com
all right
enjoy the rest of this wonderful chat
with Otsego get back into it
and we're literally right back
hey so don't don't don't let that uh
take us off the rails here this is very
interesting so when you are you were
raised by your grandma though but when
you have someone with schizophrenia in
your life not being attuned to other
people's needs isn't really an option
for you is that right yes yeah yeah
because you're just like and that's
where the general sadness for me comes
from because I just whatever I'm doing I
get to be on stage I get to you know
spend every day there's a chunk of my
day where i'm just writing jokes for me
to tell this is my job my career oh my
God I get to have fun and I'm touring
and I'm meeting fans and I make fun
videos with my husband you know at the
end of the day I always know there's in
the back of my head that my mom doesn't
get to do any of this you know and she's
just in her room cooped up without
friends you know hearing voices all day
get seizures three to four times a week
you know and so she feels like a freak
and she's lost all her teeth and you
know like that's why I have this General
sadness because I'm like oh gosh I get
to like have so much fun you know and
and so just always knowing that my mom
was always suffering even as a kid and
stuff that that made me put you know it
informed your gratitude is that it
sounds like yeah you're more grateful
because you know so extremely right
probably could have gone the other way
yeah I'm very grateful and also I just
like yeah I really love people you know
and I I really want to meet people where
they are and see them and my husband's
like that too yeah yeah and you think
that comes from the sensitivity that was
sort of I don't want to say imposed on
you but given to you you're in the
situation almost like a superpower it
made you like these empathetic
superheroes yeah is that true don't let
me put words no I think so I think so I
mean I I would love to say I was born I
was born with it right but you know I
can't help but think it it's it's from
that see my mom seeing my grandma also
raise three you know I didn't see her
raise three kids on her own but she did
yeah and then she raised me too you know
and she still takes care after my mom
and I'm the next in line to do it but
and all of that I'm so grateful for
because I I didn't have to be the
caretaker my grandma at 87 is still
taking care of her daughter wow you know
what I mean so that I don't have to yet
gosh like yeah wow I always feel a
little guilty yeah so I'm always like
shot shot oh no you know what I mean
yeah I do I do but guilty that you have
it so good and your mom has it so bad is
that yeah yeah yes yeah a little guilty
about that for sure because I go you
know I get to needle jokes you know what
I mean well it's funny because that's
true there's we're talking about
survivor's guilt sort of oh sure oh
interesting survivors Guild for
everybody meaning I I was just talking
to somebody where it was Birbiglia oh I
was like isn't it funny we I talked to
him yesterday too I bet he was making
the rounds no I called him oh you did
yeah oh interesting there we go oh wow
yeah yeah I wish he'd call me yeah
camera JK we caught another we were it
doesn't matter but I I'm actually proud
that I have a friend not just that it's
a famous friend but men do so poorly
with friends a lot of women too but like
I just never saw my dad be like God I
love Jimmy like it just never happened I
know we have a once a week call where we
check in on each other that would make
me cry what you're saying would make me
cry like I just I don't know what I
would do if I didn't have the Touchstone
he just knows it's important to have
somebody outside of your marriage Peter
like I would I would die wow yeah model
that not just model it to my daughter
but just do it from my [__] self
right but we were talking about
survivor's guilt so here we are too guys
we don't have unhealthy uh or unwell
parents but you still go isn't it
strange
that you can be flying at such a high
altitude and rarified air special life
meaning like you're saying we noodle
with jokes we get to perform it's it's a
joy right and yet you'll go like there
is
a price which will you'll happily pay
but you go like [__] you see
people in your family you see other
comedians you see sometimes you I'll
just be in a
a Waffle House in Grand Rapids Michigan
and I'm just like [__] my face like [__]
my face not I'm the king of the world
and I'm it doesn't you don't have to be
a fancy boy right if you're not
struggling in every element of your life
you're in a special place so I'm not
talking about celebrity here I'm just
saying like if you're not
if everything in your life isn't a
[__] hassle yeah you have a magical
boy or girl yes yeah you have what you
need you have what you need yeah which
is insane that that's
special yeah I know in America that's
like America the greatest country and
I'm like
most people are like Jesus like I know I
can barely keep this together and I'm
like you I don't put on shot shot shots
but I'll watch some Frasier at night
because I'm just like you need that
weight of everything and by the way of
course there are people that are
listening that are going through this
and they're like oh boo hoo Pete you
have to know about me that's what I'm
saying I'm saying we're all carrying
this burden nobody gets off
even I I can't speak for the the
multi-billionaires but I'm just saying
like we feel it because it's what's
happening right right and we see it and
we see each other's fragility it
reflects our own I don't care if you
have 100 million dollars you are in this
moment very vulnerable everybody is very
very vulnerable oh yeah and I believe it
yeah and all every comedian has a point
in their life where someone you came up
with maybe goes hey it's me right you
know and you go wow I still get to to do
it you know that's right yeah and that
happened to me at Albertsons hey it's me
oh my God yes we right I don't do it
anymore I don't do stand up anymore my
mom fell on a stroke and I had to go and
take care of her that's what she told me
right but I I I'm so proud of you she
said you know and I was like God like I
still get to do it you know I'm just
here picking up mac and cheese she's
she's you know yeah she's working there
yeah right right and she's like I
couldn't do it you know I I had to be
there for my mom in it but I'm happy you
know I you know I work here and I found
the love of my life you know but it's
just like right like you're like oh God
like you know right I'm sure people have
been like Pete hey remember sure and
then I flick a lit cigarette I tell my
driver to Florida the regulars
antagonistic normies back here Jeeves
his name is in Jeeves but everyone who
works for me I call them James oh
amazing female that doesn't matter yeah
hey [__] Jeeps lady Jeeves get that
bra higher on that tree you think the
boobs are up there it's up here
dress my trees Jeeps
oh my God
oh my God don't ever have the window
rolled down when some Riff Raff comes up
on the car ever again never and I don't
even have windows they're they're
cameras that point out and I have an HD
tv and I can roll up or down that plays
outside that's the only thing playing
all the time you're surrounding other
places I wish I was in Paris boom you're
in Paris yeah oh that's cool that's
unwell It's tricky because Jeep's
windshield he's looking at Paris too so
we've killed a lot of people
like he's just running over lots of
people in LA but we thought we were in
Paris you know what's Wild some people
would hear this and be like that's my
dream that's like that's who I want to
be Pete that's that's exactly what I
want a driver I want it to be juice I
want it to be like we kill people we
don't give a [__] that's really some
people out of this whole episode that's
what they're gonna take away from like I
didn't know that that's me I watched
that video of young Elon Musk on
Instagram and he was just getting
delivery of a million dollar car I
thought it was a deep fake because he
just looked like Ralph Wiggum but with
you know
wow he really looked like this bad
Blazer and his hair looked terrible and
I was like that's a deep fake it wasn't
a deep fake it was him and he was like
wow like three weeks ago I was sleeping
in my car now I have a million dollar
car and I was going like and you [__]
aren't happy like I can stop watching
this video like you're like here it is I
can't believe it's super cool car
when I talk about this all the time on
the Pod but it's like
we I talk about all the time having your
having your dreams come true and having
you know your needs met isn't the key to
happiness but I I want everyone to find
that out for themselves I want their
dreams to come true I want them to have
the things that they need of course but
I am there aren't any good examples of
an Elon Musk or whoever that just goes
like and you know the emptiness came
with me I got in the car I drove around
is this even his voice drove around hey
I'm buying it yeah I buy it too because
he's so not loved like no one cares like
if he was a beloved figure
Horizon grind Community doesn't like
what this impression right now but like
there's not a lot we don't even have to
get into that it's that that's my
sadness is I get really sad when I see
people that like even with every
privilege are still just kind of like
hungry ghosts is what they're called in
Buddhism you know he could be happy and
he that's just he's yeah he's not able
to show emotion as well well who the
[__] am I you know that's absolutely
true maybe that was that was like that's
the most excited
about you know what you sound a little a
little Icelandic I got up to Iceland
twice a month to buy my cigarettes
I love all your impressions you have
such range
you do yeah I can only do Icelandic
Icelandic I think everyone has an
Icelandic
way you know like Dr Evil yeah everybody
house
that's how I do it icelanders hate it
and
if it is the only thing I have the one
thing how did you find your Iceland I
think you just tighten your the back of
your throat I don't know maybe it's it's
close to Japanese a little bit do you
speak Japanese I do yeah conversational
yeah I've lost a lot of the ability you
mean like no poetic Japanese yes you
used to have some poetry in you oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yes the poetic Japanese is
gone I I talk very like just successing
you know very second grade level just
like give me this give me that like I'm
like a Russian
man kind of a Japanese stereotype that
people would just be like
it's also Russian you're right but there
are certain cultures where it's not rude
to just be like give me eat this yes yes
please eat this now I think it's broken
English but I'm just saying like even in
Japanese it sounds very like yeah yeah
yeah well correct me if I'm wrong but
it's not as flowery as we're like hey
y'all we're gonna have her
same restaurant in Japan it's like I
don't want to do the impression but I
actually I really do but I don't want to
get in trouble but it's like you know
it's time is that right it's true it's
so true I never even thought about that
I never thought what you just did with
the hey y'all booming onion I never
thought that that was
flowery it's musical it is westerners
sing their words which is why when
everybody sings they sound Western
oh geez I love playing Bono and he's
like where the streets have no name like
where's it go interesting I did not know
that I always wondered like yeah
Australians and people like that I don't
understand until they're singing and wow
goes away because we're singing all the
time I thought it's because they all
have the ability to talk like in an
American English accent normal
talk the right way I'll talk correctly
talk the right way I didn't know I
thought they always had the ability but
you know we have a hard time trying to
sound like Australians and British
people yes of course because it sounds
like an affection an affectation to us
like we're adding something Val what is
the word for them it's taking it away
right
Val's very good at helping me realize
where I'm being short-sighted
ethnocentric or something it's the
assumption that your culture is the
Baseline yes I caught myself doing I had
a bit I was in Australia and I was like
you guys realize you're talking wrong
like you're talking wrong like right now
and oh it's not you that's wrong yeah
like and she and they liked it because I
I think they're laughing at me basically
right because they also know you're
being like you know I'm saying anything
I'm not supposed to yeah yeah yeah but
because I'm saying that there's actually
kind of something loving about that like
look at this dumb thing yeah right so
you're tell me a little bit more about
the bond of the moms and the sadness we
got into survivor's guilt uh and also I
I don't know why I'm like
you're you're gonna it's like a foregone
conclusion that you'll take care of your
mom
Oh you mean like I have to do it I don't
yes that is kind of what I'm saying
because if you were my partner yeah I
would be going like are you sure and
it's not out of uncaring for your mother
right right you have to have these
conversations that there isn't there
well I guess here's the question are you
the best person to take care of your
mother I'm not yeah I'm oh my God I was
like I have the question where we both
know we're all worried yeah we're all
worried my mom included like oh
for everyone my husband's like you know
you can hire people I will I will I will
of course hire people that's why I'm
working so hard yeah rise and grind so I
could get that Elon Musk Instagram yeah
I want my million dollar car and my but
you wouldn't buy the million dollar car
because you're like a million dollars
will cover
very good care for your mom yes and then
you can visit and would she be mad at
you if you hired uh a person to take
care of her yes for sure so she should
like yell at you when you show up she'd
be like well you who do you care you
Pawn me Charles over here I don't know
what would happen I'm afraid I'm afraid
more of the depression yeah she'll get
sad because she wants you to take care
of her she would rather be with family
of course I would too I get it right so
we have a we have an ideal situation
clearly if I were a pain in the butt I
would still be like I want to be around
family yeah I've been in a pain yeah I
am a pain in the butt but see my thought
would be like I I'm gonna drag someone
down it might as well be someone I I
made
like it's like this is gonna be awful it
might as well be somebody that I own but
these are this is a difficult
conversation to have yeah wow
interesting no I don't have I don't have
it figured out I don't even know the
right questions that no I mean it
depends on why you had a kid right yeah
some people had a kid so that they could
take care of them yes when they're older
is that this is I don't want to be
ignorant but is that more of an Eastern
thing do you think I wonder yeah I'd
like oh yeah don't take care of me
that's definitely going on yeah yeah
right so they they kind of Hope like hey
you're gonna take care of me or like you
know right or either that till the
fields Lithuania was like these these
these little shits until the fields
sit on the grain keep it warm sorry yeah
I had never heard that term before the
field was like what is that yeah yeah
it's like mow the lawn and by the time
you need them they're old enough to to
Shepherd you to your grave yes yeah
that's what they hope and then and then
you can procreate and and then bring
continue the name too right so it's very
modern yeah two things that are very
modern atheism that's that's not a uh
that's not shots fired it's a very
modern phenomena yes that there's no God
yes most of recorded time it was just a
foregone conclusion that you would have
some belief system whether that's right
or wrong it doesn't matter I'm just
stating a fact two also very modern
phenomenon I I am a incredibly 20 22
person that would say I don't expect my
daughter to take care of me like that's
new yes that is new very very new and if
she tried to I would say unless I was
desperate and absolutely there was
nobody to help but I would be like I
would rather Charles
than you or I'm gonna Charles Schwab
yeah oh let's hope Charles Schwab takes
care of me
uh I it would and let's spin this back
to you but if if my daughter were taking
care of me
um
sure there would be some comfort to that
but I think it would be eclipsed by the
fact that I'd be like you shouldn't be
doing this oh and I I want you to live a
good life like and this is a tough
conversation yeah no no but that's true
like that's that is a modern way of
thinking and where we always needed to
put a reason behind why we do something
yeah and maybe you don't like have to
like what do you mean oh look I'm having
a kid because of course the right family
name winter is coming yes and yeah these
fields exactly and I think more and more
you don't need a reason to have a kid
but I'm having a daughter so she'll have
I'm literally Val and I are sun and
water and she's a plant that's it we're
just trying to have her my mom guilts me
with this all the time like she's like
why don't you come home for Christmas
and I'll be like well Christmas about
Leela and we don't want to be traveling
and just being honest like I don't feel
good as I'm telling her something I know
she doesn't want to hear oh yeah but
she's like wait till you because she's
guilting me she'll stop herself but
she'll be like wait till you see when
Lila's older and she and I'll go like if
Leela tells me I want to spend Christmas
with my family because that makes me
happy yeah nothing would make me happier
I'm not saying that I wouldn't be like a
little rejected or whatever it is yes
like I want her to be happy more than I
want myself to be happy and like yeah
that's tricky and maybe she's calling
[__] on that she would say you'll
see that's not how it works you're
you're going to be miserable you'll be
pissed yeah you'll be pissed yeah I know
yeah I know I would be already hearing
this I'd be like oh no I'd be so sad so
you it how does that inform your because
right now today as it stands yeah you're
uh Papa you have to take over uh-huh
yeah you do that what's your attitude
towards doing that that's water okay
thank you there's a little bit of orange
in it I'm gonna drink something because
my my stomach is growling and I was like
oh that's gonna be so loud and maybe if
I drink no no no I think no nobody wants
to stop chewing yeah nobody wants to
hear that that's done yeah no no no
thank you okay yeah you feel going into
that yeah no I uh I'm I'm I'm such a
blind Optimist I think it's I can
totally do it and I have already an
ideal situation that I've told my
husband that I've convinced him to also
think he agrees you know you know what I
mean because you inceptioned him yeah
I've said it enough where I'm like it'll
be good it's gonna be so fun right like
for her to live in the guest house
behind us and we we can only you know
I've said it like that where I'm like
you only have to see her like once a
week I'll I'll go over there and you
know it'll be so fun right like I I
literally talk like that like a
psychopath and and but that's what
you're doing to yourself yeah that's
true I I apologize
the voice that you have going oh my God
P I never thought of that is this why
you drive quietly in the car because
you're going like she'll be in the cat
it'll be good so you're like once or
twice because and I'm not even making
fun of you I'm just saying these wow
situations that's so true I'd never
thought of that and then marriage is
often and I do this without you start to
see the scripts that you're running
yourself and now you have to say them
out loud to another person because we
need to be a unified front wow oh my
gosh yeah I I yeah I need to see a
therapist I I didn't know I was unwell
I thought I was just like this was an
optimist being an optimist I don't think
you're unwell well you are dealing with
something that needs to be dealt with it
I'm over here the issue of whether or
not I go home for Christmas is not even
an issue right it's like a
it's enough you're fine with it yes yeah
it's something I do for entertainment
and even my mom does it for
entertainment even the feeling of like I
wish is that the movie she gets to watch
and my feeling of like am I a bad son
that's the movie I get to watch but like
we're not dealing with life and death
and medical dependency right that's true
yeah so
yeah but I am still gonna be like
is it a cliche that you go to La you get
an HBO special you do your different you
do your quibby
hey go ahead
yeah
I knew those fighting words are gonna be
brought up
I didn't even know about it until I
researched you for that oh yeah but uh
quibby um it's just such a funny word
anyway it is
it is kind of a cliche
um
especially if you're an immigrant is
that the correct term I never know when
it's immigrant emigrated oh yeah yeah
did they used to say with an e in the
beginning yeah
NPR and they're like they emigrated and
I'm like sorry Ira sorry what did that
mean yeah they immigrated but they were
on Ecstasy
but anyway so you're especially an
immigrant you there's more heat on you
coming to not just the west but the West
West LA Hollywood right your train comes
in you get uh success you get some money
um is the eye roll even greater if you
were to hire Charles one of my
one of my Jeeves yeah one of my many
disposable jeans I would be honored if
one of your stuff
that's the whole pleasure of having a
flock of Jeeves uh-huh right I'll just
Dick Cheney one of them in the face it's
too dark too dark they don't die they
don't they're like minions yeah they're
minions yes exactly yes so you have your
Jeeves and you say Jeeves take care of
my mother everyone in the west would be
like of course but is it is it safe to
say that a lot of people
would look at you uh cross probably feel
more heat because of the clicheiness of
like yeah someone comes to the west and
becomes westernized yeah probably a
little bit but I also it's it's not even
that that so much it's it's me wanting
to uh do it because I maybe I don't want
to feel the guilt maybe I'm you know
because I I that General sadness will
get greater if I knew that I put her
somewhere else right or something and
what about sorry yeah no go ahead of
Jeeves that lives in your back house
yeah so it's still at your house but you
got a Jesus back there yes that's what I
mean we just fix it yes so the ideal
situation there's a guest house my mom's
there there's a Jeeves there there's a
Jeeves there yeah so as we're a big
family it's not like I call you to do
Largo and you're like I can't I I'm
completely oh yeah caregiver oh yeah
that's kind of what I thought you were
saying yes I'm being honest that you
were gonna be a full-time caregiver
yeah because then we can still have do
the dinners we could do breakfast
together what is it like whoa what it
was just my pen what is it like hanging
out with your mom
um it's it's a it's a lot it's probably
like kind of like a kid you know just
like needs but maybe more like a oh gosh
maybe more like an infant like a lot of
needs and then what are the needs oh I'm
thirsty I'm hungry I'm just saying I
this is this how babies are yeah I I
don't hang out with babies because I
don't have one but is she dependent
because physically is she incapable of
she she is uh capable of like doing
things but she's just I think just with
like you know she just lays down a lot
because the she's just always her
medication makes her so sleepy yeah so
she is a little like
not a vegetable but she you know she's
dependent she's dependent yeah yeah she
She lays down a lot she doesn't she
can't stand for too long so she likes to
ask for things you know she needs things
she sometimes can't make it to the
restroom in time so she wears diapers
stuff like that
um and so yeah and then but then she
when she does talk when she gets to
talking she loves the Arts she's
actually very very smart well versed in
the Arts she loves art history she knows
how she she knows better than my grandma
how jokes work and stuff really just
because she watches a lot of TV so
she'll watch variety shows with
comedians on it and she knows you know
she knows how jokes should be
um are these like Windows of clarity or
like does it go come and go I really
just know anything about this yeah so if
you actually or is it like what's that
excuse me actually yeah we're getting
into schizophrenia exactly yeah yeah so
are there pockets of Lucidity or is it
always just kind of like in an hour is
it like oh she was clear for an hour
yeah more like she was clear for 10
minutes and then she was unclear for
yeah whatever the term is yeah it really
depends on when the voices start coming
in okay yeah especially know who the
voices are yes it's like seven people
from her Village back in Taiwan uh you
know but and they say very negative
things all day all day no good voice no
good voice it's all about how she's
failed as a person and so so it's just a
lot and so that's when she'll not be
able to communicate because you know
she's trying to fight them off right and
so I'm not trying to be funny she is
communicating she's communicating she is
no it's very true it's true reality yeah
that's what's happening yes she's she is
actually constantly constantly
communicating and constantly has uh
but I guess some people around her yeah
in a weird way yeah oh that's
interesting yeah yeah because there is
that is true to her I I know that I hope
it is it's true it's disturbing but it's
like her mind would be making that very
real to her yeah I wish the voices were
yeah kind yeah yeah totally right but
that's like a movie version right that's
a beautiful mind yes that yeah is that
how that movie goes I never watched it
but I was like oh math problem so he's
like a mathematician yeah he's brilliant
they're actually in the way as well oh
okay okay they end up being mean in fact
I don't know too many nice voice stories
but it's interesting as tempting as it
may be to other your mom isn't Eckhart
Tolle has this great point where he's
like you see someone walking on the
street a home on house person
both homeless on and on house to please
everybody
yeah yeah yeah no I say both yeah yeah
yeah but you see somebody that does not
have a home that is walking around and
they are yelling to themselves and
Eckhart Tolle is like what's the
difference they're just doing out loud
what we're all doing right which is true
like it's true so as much as I'd like to
scapegoat your mother and be like I
don't have of course I do they're not
audible in the way
this is I I think there's a very
interesting subject yeah I can hear a
voice in my head oh you can it's my
thoughts so oh yeah right I'm thirsty I
should drink something yeah stomach is
grumbling yeah you heard those yes yes
that's normal right that's or maybe
that's what I'm saying basic reality is
an exercise in
I don't want to say Insanity because
because of what we're talking about but
like
um you could say magic or you could say
strangeness yeah why like I can hear a
voice that says right now as we're
talking again it's not really a voice
because I'm not taking the time to
articulate it but it goes like thoughts
yeah I bet we're about at a minute an
hour and 40 minutes so we'll round you
know like while we're talking that's
normal I just have a bit about this I
was like it's crazy to hear voices in
your head but it's not crazy to hear
songs in your head so the rule of the
society is if you hear a voice that's
crazy unless it's singing if it's Sting
singing Fields of Gold you're not crazy
that to me
I think schizophrenia can be this harsh
mirror that we're all living in
a a reality of our own making yeah that
we interpret this completely normal to
us but if you were in my brain I know
this is very basic like Stoner thoughts
I know I love it no to ward off the
occasional you know my mom floats by or
my dad floats by right different voice
it's it's significant that these are
voices from her Village in Taiwan where
she grew up these super ego shaming
right you know thoughts we all have that
yes so I'm just trying to say
yeah like it's not that strange yeah
it's just it's an exaggeration of what's
already happening I think so too all the
time yeah we're at 90. yeah and
sometimes because it's an exaggeration
oh nice because oh you were close yeah
but you have to we're constantly having
multiple thoughts at the same time wow
we're always multitasking of course and
I always say God I should be be careful
you know because it is like uh but back
to really quick her it's her it's just
an exaggeration of how we all kind of uh
move about in the world and think every
day
um because of that when she like when
she has
um sometimes she's been I feel like a
future teller I feel like my mom has
like psychic ability sometimes look I'm
this kind of person but yeah if she's
if her reality is getting blurred and I
don't want to perpetuate some stereotype
if there's a stereotype that unwell
people are magical you know I don't want
to do no no but because she's able to
tap into that's she spends so much time
with just her thoughts yeah that she's
able to she's trying to she's she's
warned me about things that I'm like I
didn't see it because I was so busy with
my own ego and walking around trying to
make friends I cared about what other
people were thinking about me while she
didn't you know and so she was able to
know the truth faster I mean it's just
little things like dumb things that
you'd be like oh no literally that she
was like the church they're all
Hypocrites and as a 10 year old I was I
became such a Jesus Freak because you
know when you they get immigrants very
easily because they're like do you want
friends or not do you want to belong
come to church so then I was like yeah I
want friends and then there was lunch
too free every Sunday everybody you're
right in my sweet spot and everyone has
to accept you and be nice to you right
ideally yes you see this a lot yeah so I
went my grandma me because my uncle who
we were living in his garage of uh he
was going to church so we all went
together my mom would refuse to go uh
she and and then every week she'd be
like you know there's just you know
they're they're people still okay like
don't get too into them you know they're
still people so it's like maybe the
beliefs are good but you know yeah treat
people kind but are they actually doing
that interesting you know and I was like
oh they are though they are though and
then you know I started seeing things
that
um she woke you up to and she never even
set foot on the church she just knew
because she just knows how people are
anything but I was a kid so I my mind
was blonde how did you know I saw them
turn away a homeless unhoused person
they wanted who wanted free lunch right
yeah how'd you know she's like because
the people it's other people so they're
gonna anything else any other time she
saw
um I think she you she knew kovid was
gonna hit the states too really yeah
yeah pretty fast but she also just
watches a lot of like Asian news so she
just saw like the first cases with her
but she was like she was like it'll
probably we'll probably lock down by
March and I was like no I have comedy
shows mom I'm going to do shows like all
of March hilarious she's like probably
like first week of March will all be
locked down all of the states wow
they're like no Mom you're wild what are
you talking about we got good doctors
and stuff
scientists and stuff they said it's just
going to be a month she's like it's
gonna be a while she was right she was
right just because she's just with her
thoughts and she watches patterns right
you know that's interesting she's not
trying to do comedy shows
well she doesn't have a narrative that
she is deeply invested in maintaining
yeah yeah as you and I do she's not the
center of her Universe right you
literally have a tour schedule it's
Insanity that you don't think about me
both have tour schedules because we're
predicting where we'll be in the future
yes I know which is wild I'll be there
on like I know again it's totally normal
yeah but I'm like after this I'm going I
don't know that no I know I always get
spooked I'm like okay yeah August 12th
I'm gonna be there but we also love it
yeah yeah because then you're you've
basically made yourself God you're like
I will be not not in a big that's true
yeah in a little way yeah and not even
in a bad way I'm just saying it's this
comforting thing to be like uh like you
love being on the phone being like I
have a flight
to Philly yeah yeah yeah
you're like yeah
no that's so interesting that's what
covid was obviously I don't have to say
this but I will just to make sure
everyone knows that I know huge tragedy
what what a devastating loss for
Humanity a horrible thing and there's
this like lesson of like we'll all be
the people that had that happen and
they'll be just a little bit more
glimmer in our eye when we're like you
don't know what's going to happen yeah
like I thought it was going to be in
Cleveland and it got everything got
locked down right yeah no Cleveland if
you were Jesus freak I was a Jesus freak
I went to Jesus Camp I signed up on my
own even when my own youth group was
like when we're not going this year I'll
be like okay I'll go on my own like a
wild person yeah to Jesus camp and I
went to Jesus Camp yeah we watched that
movie where they're holding up the call
Jesus Camp
I think it's they get straight to the
point you know the documentary about
Jesus can't call Jesus Camp yeah that
movie was difficult to watch yes because
you do see so much earnest
desire for a connection to a higher
power and to purpose and to community
right and all of these other things are
stapled to it like everyone you know is
going to hell right Reproductive Rights
if that's if that's the thing that's
that's definitely coming up uh
homosexuality all these things that you
didn't ask for right I'm projecting on
to you I was like I want 11 God I want
I'm afraid of dying I'd like that to be
taken care of I'd like some Community
all the stuff and then you get all that
and look there with the pizza and the
youth group and then slowly like you you
just start it's it's a tragedy yeah
because that part didn't have to be a
part of it no yeah but it ends up
becoming a part of it I'm trying to
write a bit about this where I was like
wow yeah we don't want Mercy we we hate
Mercy we don't want a God that loves
everybody we want a God that loves us
and hates everybody else just like us
yeah it's so true yeah take over your
experience before I keep going and on
and on and on no it's so true stuff I
mean I was so entranced in Trend uh what
is it entranced by trans or entrenched
entrenched entrenched entranced everyone
who's entrenched is entranced yeah not
everyone who's in chance is enchant is
that right yeah
I learned so many words on this end this
session alone this is your therapy
session yeah yeah no no we are on a
couch yeah
um
yeah I uh
Christians love outdoor activities sure
so there's a lot of that so it was just
like oh this is actual Camp you know it
was really it was easy to get lost in
that we're playing Capture the Flag
we're playing tag uh we're painting
murals and stuff and then uh and then it
gets really intense the you know the
main game that we were supposed to play
that weekend was at night in the forest
because this Camp happened in the forest
of like big bear or something so it was
really dark and you were supposed to put
on backpacks with Bibles in it
and across from one end of the forest
I'm 14. yeah across from one and on the
floor we only cross we only cross knows
exactly carry over no yeah no zigzags
everyone move in a lowercase T pattern
no zigzags that's for other for
non-believers
and so they were like there's gonna be
the camp counselors are gonna be because
they then they told the story about her
like you know in China missionaries are
going to prison being for being caught
trying to spread the word of the Lord
and and with they're getting caught with
their Bibles and their backpacks when
they're trying to cross the river to get
to China or whatever so that's the
experience you all are gonna
feel tonight
that's the experience you're all going
to feel tonight yeah so suddenly it
always becomes scary right it's a
Christian Camp Capture the Flag tag
murals and it became Chinese people
smuggling Bibles across the river yes so
yes immediately we were all cosplaying
you know cross-playing cross-play we
were cross-playing we were all playing
yeah Chinese
yes and yeah so is this and what
happened if you got caught if you got
caught they ask you one question do you
believe in Jesus if you say yes you get
fake killed shot or whatever and then
put into and then you go to heaven but
for the holding spaces were like these
sheds until in the end we can count who
all said yes and ended up thinking and
saying no people uh no I don't believe
in Jesus the people the kids who want to
actually win the game and continue
living and finish the if you say no they
leave you alone they leave you alone
yeah they leave you alone and they go
yeah okay keep walking and then you end
up at the end of the forest where you
know you have not been caught but you've
walked with the guilt that you said no
you don't believe in Jesus and everyone
knows because I'm just curious isn't
that wild kids that's a wild game who
doesn't see the switcheroo coming yes
it's dedicated to believing in Jesus
they're like so if you say no you get to
win the game everyone sees that like
psych you're the loser like it's true
yes but you know when you're in a game
of like pretty much tag I get it hide
and seek and tag you're like I want to
win do you love your mother no
yeah exactly yeah you're like a 12 year
old boy yeah yeah so what did you say I
said yes like a loser yeah and I got
fake shot and I I remember I remember
even being like Oh shooting you this is
terrible it's so frightening I'm like so
young pretty young 14. you were saying
you remember I remember when they fake
shot me I even like I was so moved that
I said yes and that I did something good
you know and so I remember even when
they fake shot me going oh like I did
the physical movement of getting shot
and fell backwards like a [__] loser
like and then and then they've got okay
so now you're gonna get up they're like
okay and they taught me hey so you're
gonna get up and walk to the sheds so
that's where you'll be held I was like
okay thank you and like turned back into
like instructions oh my God it's so
anyway so that's
yeah it's the scary stuff that they feed
you to with the games and well that's
there was that dark Hell House too which
is the haunted house that was hell yeah
it's funny how we will use uh Christian
Gospel to just do what everyone else is
doing like we want to play a murder game
yes you want to play Murder sneaky it's
so lame famous oh no it's very lame it's
like we have this annoying guy Jesus
who's just telling us to love each other
and be kind and to you know all that's
good stuff yeah but we still want to
like can I shoot this 14 year old man
and can we make a haunted house like
it's like having your cake and eating it
too it's like yeah we're about love and
light and forgiveness but also like go
in this haunted house under the guise
that it'll scare you into believing in
my loving system like is that how you
attract people with fear and is that is
it would you like to go anywhere that
fear brought you that's a good question
to ask no I'm here with fear it's like
Christian rap or something it is where
it's like oh see we still throw down
beats right you know shots shots shots
cross cross cross cross cross cross
cross
everybody
where are you at now I'm I don't go to
church my yeah I don't go to church and
I don't I don't know if I'm a atheist I
just don't think about him what's that
what's that called that's a bit I don't
know if I'm an atheist I just don't
think about him I don't that's a bit
that's ready to go that's funny today
it's like you were saying you were
saying somebody that you'd never think
about too me flavor flavor oh maybe it's
whatever fun you know it's just like I
just yeah I don't I don't think about
him when I wake up yeah yeah yeah oh I
didn't mean to put him on a shelf no I
didn't meet yet like an elf on a shelf
but it's Jesus yeah uh so you're just
kind of like taking a it sounds like a
much needed break I feel like you put in
your time getting headshots yeah yeah I
got tired I was like oh man I was a
soldier for God but do you have any
inkling just today
we're both alive we're both on a planet
yeah we both know it's not forever I
don't mean fear like afterlife I just
mean like
what what do you have any inkling on
like what's going on here is it
meaningless is it meaningful is it yeah
I think we're all trying our best and
then so that is Meaningful yeah you know
we're all trying our best being in a
place that we don't really ask for you
know and being in bodies we didn't
really ask for and so we're all trying
our best considering yes and that's
again sort of the optimistic view I have
but I don't really think about where we
go after at all do you think this
there's something do you think you are
your body lights out dead when you get
shot smuggling Bibles
so two you think it's over yeah I I mean
I think that yes yeah yeah yeah and you
do too
didn't you I feel like you had a bit
about being atheist and like the
comedians or like atheists and that's
like the cigarette I believe that's
right yes yeah like the motorcycle I
believe like to have nothing yeah yeah
nothing but that one that I'm trying to
get going that I just can't make that
funny is like
the reason why death is frightening to
in a materialist not necessarily an
atheist but atheist materialist
perspective is that when you die you go
into nothing and that doesn't mean empty
space that means the void I mean you
can't even imagine it nothing
but the same materialist worldview would
tell you that the Universe erupted from
nothing so why are we so sure that it's
the end if all of the energy goes into
the void and the void is the breeding
ground for everything why can't you be
the part of this undulating
self-replicating and recycling energy
that everything else is including your
awareness and maybe even including your
separateness meaning
even if you don't believe in God there's
hope in that you believe the world came
out of nothing and then when you die you
go into nothing yeah which is at the end
except when it's the beginning you
understand yeah it's nothing except when
it's everything and it became everything
for no reason so like for all you know
you die you go into nothing what a great
place to be yeah the birthplace of
infinite potential I agree I don't say
that with uh sadness at all yeah I would
love that to be nothing yeah yeah I'm
totally into it yeah I'm not like oh I
need a place to be for not that yeah
people are going to be like oh God you
think you're we're such losers no it's
just it sounds wild to me sometimes I
want to let's continue living forever
and ever and sing and singing and stuff
well the idea yeah that's that's wild
it's like you know we deserve rest it's
okay I the idea of going into again
words fail is here but in afterlife
something that isn't being in these
physical bodies but that what I what you
and I were raised in places like Jesus
Camp was that I Pete would know that I
was in heaven and God was over there and
I'm singing to him that to me
I I just think we need to as as father
Greg Boyles wrong God like that's just
the wrong like whoops wrong like that
because
one of the faults that I can have with
any any religion that perpetuates the
idea that you are a separated ego that
when it dies that ego is judged and is
either rewarded or punished is so ego
affirming and so separateness affirming
yeah and whenever I look at spirituality
and mysticism at its deeper levels it's
always pointing at it's one it's one
thing or it's no thing and that's where
we go so I don't think you and I are
going to be going like remember on the
podcast like we're dead that's when we
talk about this is this weird I know I
don't think because that's Duality I
don't even think I'll be like I'm
[__] because that feeling is based in
Duality [__] is defined by the
feeling of not [__] why'd I have to
pick [__] but you know what I'm
saying wow that's interesting yeah yeah
yeah Thomas Merton says I don't know
much about heaven but there won't be
much of you there right so when we think
about it in ego terms even being sent to
hell is an ego trip the the president of
the universe hated me what's more
special than that he couldn't [__]
stand me he wanted to punish me he was
shaking his fist at me that's an ego
trip wow that's just affirming your
separateness
you must do better with trolls than me
then if you're like they're thinking
about me so that's nice
I would say all of that and I use the
term lightly but victim-ness being like
this [__]
posted that comment on this [__] you is
another ego trip to be like I'm innocent
and he's guilty and it's a way of
scapegoating my own guilt oh I just
think it could be the guilt that came
from separating from God this guilt that
I shouldn't even be here that we're
supposed to be what we're like [__] you
yeah yeah so we do like being victims to
a certain extent I mean all of us yeah
for sure I love being angry yeah and we
love being right yeah and we love uh
projecting all of our evil onto everyone
else and and we were even I was even
doing that earlier with Elon Musk I'm
like oh he has a million dollar car yeah
Pete you have a 400 toilet seat like eat
[__] like you know what I'm saying like
we can't stop doing it right right
because we either love being we want to
be the good one yeah but it doesn't or
the bad one oh I was driving here and I
saw somebody on their back windshield it
said Unholy and I was like yeah we'll
take it either way all we want is to
exist and to know we exist and to know
it's not our fault so either we'll be
guilty or will be innocent but one thing
we can't tolerate is being no thing
being nothing being one with everything
and that's mercy and that's heaven and
that actually sounds like hell to us
would rather be here yeah farting and
punching and right [__] and eating
because the idea of merging into gods or
or the Oneness of everything we don't
have to call it God that actually sounds
like hell to us I think that's one of
the problems we're here to overcome wow
yeah you really
I'm so glad you don't listen to music in
your car like you
this is this is this this is what you
think about
this is like really important stuff this
is like important to think about
I'm so glad you're not like
it's so funny but what are we doing here
yeah we're merging we love merging yeah
remembering the Oneness that's why I'm
asking you questions about what it felt
like and the motivator how you feel
about your mother
unifying feels so good the comedy show
is is spiritual it's this unifying thing
right and that troll is separating all
these things that we hate are are these
separations these rude Awakenings yeah
from we could be having a better dream
right no it's true the end wow
amazing do I ring a bell no I don't know
I do Hey Jude I feel like you sing a
song
right I feel like here's what we do very
dangerous you can like talking like that
if there were three like one more person
boom that's how a cult starts
there are some podcasts where there are
people manning the cameras and stuff we
don't do that oh my God you know we're
wearing sashes yeah because I'll be like
we want to be something not no thing and
that's like also yeah
no it's so true you're really fun okay
this is what we do because this happens
most episodes they'll be like this but
what do we do now
we do these questions can you tell me
first of all do you feel satisfied is
there anything else you wanted to say
about no I feel great okay yeah
um
can you tell me a time in your life that
you laughed really really really really
really really really really really hard
and it doesn't have to be a good story
yeah I also I really love this show
called Cobra Kai sure and I don't know
if you've seen it but it's like season
three I I love it for many reasons you
know it's like anyone love it really I
love it I love it I don't mean it like
that Katie I didn't say people
I would say people I like yeah yeah but
is it a kitschy love or like you just
like what they're doing I receive it
yeah they're so committed they they
they're so sincere about that
storytelling so even if it's cheesy the
stakes are high for them but when you
watch it you're not watching it like
ironically silly or something oh no I
know you do love Cobra I'm only saying
it because it's called Cobra Kai that's
really all I like it's a Karate Kid
spin-off yes okay yeah and that's why I
was assuming maybe it was corny but I
don't know anything about it no it is
corny but because they the actors
believe it they're in it they're in it
the the karate in the valley like the
all Valley tournament that's like very
important I know it sounds so silly and
it is silly no it is silly All In All
Valley Karate but that that's such a big
deal to them and that's why I love it
and Johnny Lawrence who is a character
in Karate Kid he was the main antagonist
I love that he has a comeback you know
and he gets to you know I think is he a
bad guy still he's uh he's sort of he's
like a bad guy but his true self is good
and but he's not so smart you know he he
likes beer and I bought this painting
because I thought I'm supposed to look
make it look nice to impress this girl
he's like that and he and he's trying to
connect with the son of his girlfriend
you know and he loves and he wants to be
his father figure so he's telling him
genuine sincerely I want I wanted to
take you somewhere nice
um and I'm not gonna crush this because
the delivery is so good it's the way he
says this he says I wanted to take you
somewhere nice Marie callenders
Applebee's Olive Garden stuff like that
and it kills me it kills me and I I've
rewatched it for like so many times and
he's sincere about it he sits him down
to tell him this and he really means and
it Crush kills me yes I wanted to take
you somewhere nice Marie Callender's
Applebee's Olive Garden stuff like that
that is a great answer yeah so that's
that's what makes me laugh because it's
kind of it's heartwarming too it's
heartwarming it's both it's funny but
it's also it's funny that it's not funny
and he means it and it's beautiful see
this is you it's like you you have all
this beauty and all this empathy in you
that even your funny like so many people
on the show it's like I saw someone fall
face and you're like I saw a dad trying
to connect with his son example of
somewhere nice was Olive Garden that's
still pretty funny yeah yes and he
sincerely meant that stuff he really
meant it and stuff like that it's like
Etc stuff like that like he you know and
stuff like that is really what killed me
I can't believe Etc made it it's killing
it the first one that said Etc yeah Etc
yeah [__] was that something we'll all
say for the rest of recording yeah I
know some other dork was like we need
something different for people they're
like at all at all at all it's for
people but I never even got that Etc and
at all yeah for all yeah at all
oh God and writ large comes to mind
this is grammar it's not Grammar but you
understand Oscar this is awesome this
this was awesome did you enjoy I did
thank you so much for having me are you
kidding thank you for the the drinks yes
of course oh my God yeah oh Nirvana
Water that's also yeah the the water is
so tasty it's so delicious and it
prevents muscle loss and I think it
speeds up your metabolism it says it on
the side read it there oh yeah you don't
have to read it no it does that's that's
why that's why I'm starving
I'm just losing weight so quick I'm just
losing weight yeah you're sitting here
you're wasting away and that's what that
water was designed for people that waste
away
um thank you very much we end with the
guests saying the catchphrase which is
keep it crispy it's just how we sign off
if they keep it crispy that and then
we'll be done let's do it keep it crispy
you do have a special way of talking
like sometimes people do Supercuts of
all the keep it Crispies we'll all know
that was you well done
thanks for having me
a little bit oh yeah
[Music]